okay on to the next game on greenhaven
the opponent from USA 23 sound to our go
for some on the edge shadow line let's
see always going from Bishop g5 set up
yeah no idea i don't i don't play this
some opening on a regular basis
yeah yeah we reach the Benoni structure
with them white not playing it for this
is some interesting setup it's rather
solid and doesn't allow any quick
counter place because i like the point
on you for 21 to have some some counter
play against also i cannot easily play
e6 here because d6 is hanging I'm not
sure what could be a good plan here
maybe I should try to to grab the bishop
pair at least yea which was successful
still it's um not easy at all to to gain
some counter play here 95 maybe I get
kicked with that format i can drop to g6
let's show what is this can upload can
play e6 RSS to lose after taking an ID
for now probably it is
you have a tea maybe it's got the idea
to exchange and then to Queen h4 h5 hmm
looks pretty uncomfortable I must admit
what is just better in this position
what what can you do yeah my ID extras
the 28 now we take sanji five now I have
Knight to e5 and i hope this would get
me some kind of play actually i think
taking on g5 isn't a really good idea
for white at this point he's got yeah
it's got plenty of other good moves like
this one for instance um came maybe I
can go G for now night eh hi can I can
just exchange which isn't too bad I
guess
hmm
not sure such such a bad position his
queen position isn't isn't ideal at all
so okay can they can go you for of
course but not sure which I gotta get
this now he takes now rook rook air-five
looks time money looks very good
yeah of course but what about just
pushing the edge porn here
of course I don't want it to take on the
form
the exchange is now the ledge for still
a major idea I just close this here
you
yeah i simply i simply don't have have
enough time in this position
it still looks very playable this night
doesn't have any active ideas at all I
can't do anything as well ah ok I just
blend at the exchange still quickly draw
this position draw our third ok it's fun
he will decline technically it's a
complete draw because it position is one
hundred percent blocked
it's quite funny you can't do anything
just offer G Harvard game drawn so very
rare that people offer you draw a few
bits two seconds very nice of him the
position is really a draw take quite
fascinating I think I think at some
point maybe it was it was even a fine
position for me but of course it was
very difficult to play and i got really
um to too little time to to make
something of it it's really a problem if
you play an opening like this been only
structure and you have very little
experience some at least i tend to spend
so much time that i have problems
playing properly at least at the end of
the game because it's simply a matter of
seconds all the time